Speaker 1: Ladies and gentlemen, Republicans
have suffered a completely humiliating defeat
last night, losing really badly their attempt
to recall Democratic California Governor Gavin
Newsom and to replace him with there was really
only one person who might have replaced Newsom
if the vote had gone yes on recall rather
than no.
And that is the absolutely radical Republican
named Larry Elder.
Now, we're going to go through some different
aspects of this story here.
But the big narrative is mostly right wingers
in California, despite claims that the left
also isn't happy with Gavin Newsom, some Democrats
are not happy with Gavin Newsom, but by and
large, mostly the right wing of California,
many of them pro Trump, decided to try to
remove the governor, Gavin Newsom.
The top alternative was a Republican named
Larry Elder, who agrees with Donald Trump
on 99 percent of everything.
The only disagreement I was able to find between
Larry Elder and Donald Trump was that Larry
Elder didn't like the Chinese tariffs that
Donald that Donald Trump put in place.
But beyond that, this was a guy who was not
only pro Trump, but in some cases even beyond
Trump, saying he would end every mass requirement
if he were to become governor.
He would end every vaccine requirement if
he were to become governor.
He has a long history of deranged political
statements, misogynistic statements, homophobic
statements, racist statements even.
And he got absolutely crushed.
In terms of the first question, the recalls
are a two part question.
The first question is, should Governor Newsom
be recalled?
70 percent reporting this morning.
Mail in ballots left to be counted, but 64
percent of voters said no.
Newsom should not be recalled.
Basically a two to one loss for those seeking
to remove Gavin Newsom.
I mean, just a resounding and humiliating
defeat.
Now, had the recall gone, yes, remove Gavin
Newsom, then it would have gone to the second
question and it would have been Larry Elder,
who became the governor of California.
Elder got 47 percent of the question to vote,
followed by friend of the show, Kevin PADF.
Wrath, who ran as a Democrat, called into
the live stream we did last night.
Nice guy.
Although my position all along has been just
vote no.
Do not recall Gavin Newsom.
So it was going to be Larry Elder if Newsom
didn't stay.
Now, this is a major bullet dodged and a major
humiliation for Republicans.
And this is also, to some degree, a referendum
on Trump ism, this entire take them out attitude,
replace them with a pro Trump Republican.
This is to some degree, a signal about the
power of Trump ism, which may be we don't
we don't know yet.
The power of Trump ism may be diminishing.
We won't really know until November of twenty,
twenty two.
But it is a good sign that this movement failed
and failed so miserably at attempting to replace
the sitting Democratic governor with a Trump
and lunatic Republican in Larry Elder.
Now, what exactly happened here?
How did this all end up the way it ended up?
Well, remember that early on and we have the
polling, a trajectory for this race up on
the screen now for people who are watching
early on, there was a long period of time,
about three, four weeks in August where the
polling was almost completely tied.
And we were worried about that.
It was it was it wasn't too close.
It was tied between keep and remove Gavin
Newsom.
But two different things were going on.
First, in a recall, the people wanting the
recall are often more engaged for a period
of time since everybody else is just living
their lives, they're not looking to be involved
in a recall.
This isn't a scheduled election.
And so as more and more Californians learned
about the recall and its paramount importance,
you saw more and more say, no, I'm actually
going to get involved.
I'm a likely voter now and I want to keep
Gavin Newsom.
Secondly, the most important issue for recall
voters was covid.
And so, as Larry Elder explained, he said,
I would get rid of every guideline around
covid.
As Delta grew in August, Larry Elder's cartoonish
position on covid only helped Gavin Newsom
even more.
And ultimately, it went very much in Gavin
Newsom's favor.
Let's look at a couple of different clips
here as Fox News eventually calling it.
I think this was after 1:00 a.m.. Dave Wasserman
called this at like 11, 15 Eastern Time, I
think this was like around 1:00 a.m.
This was Fox News calling it last night.
Speaker 2: Steve, stand by, because the Associated
Press is now just called it.
You see the numbers on the bottom of your
screen.
See the check mark there?
Sixty seven point three.
Thirty two, yes.
That means that Gavin Newsom will not be recalled.
The Associated Press has now called it.
You've got 58 percent of the
Speaker 1: vote in there.
It is.
And actually that may have been earlier.
And then Larry Elder eventually came out and
spoke.
This may have been around 1:00 a.m.
Eastern.
Elder finally saying we may have lost the
battle, but we have not lost the war.
Speaker 2: Let's be gracious.
Let's be gracious in defeat.
And by the way, we may have lost the battle,
but we are going to win the war.
Speaker 1: So at the end of the day, this
was just a bad idea and it was an expenditure
of political capital for doing nothing other
than being resoundingly defeated and spending
more than two hundred and fifty million dollars
to do this this optional recall election,
which wasn't even close.
There was no shot at removing Gavin Newsom,
250 million dollars.
The very same people complaining about profligate
government spending.
Acted to spend two hundred and fifty million
dollars on an election that ended up humiliating
them and also was completely unnecessary.
Now there are some right wingers who are turning
around and saying this failed because California
is full of stupid liberals.
Just get out of California.
And Ben Shapiro basically tweeted as much
last night saying, quote, The failure of the
California recall is a reminder to Republicans
still in the state.
The decline is now inexorable.
Get out while the getting is good and move
to a purple or red state.
Your life will radically improve.
Well, that's fine.
And let's see if people do it.
We have freedom of movement in the United
States between states.
The California exodus that they've been claiming
is going on for a long time hasn't actually
been going on.
And they also for being free marketeers, they
seem to miss the fact that the reason in part
that things are expensive in California is
because there's a lot of demand to live in
California in those parts, much of California
is actually dirt cheap.
If you get away from the popular areas on
the coasts and some inland cities, there's
a lot of California that is really, really
cheap.
Why is it so expensive to live in Santa Barbara,
a tiny city of 90000 people, versus just to
pick a place with a similar population?
Parma, Ohio.
Maybe you've never heard of Parma, Ohio, maybe
you have the reason Santa Barbara is more
expensive is because more people want to live
in Santa Barbara because it's nicer with better
schools, access to better airports, better
infrastructure.
And California ranks fifth in health care
compared to Ohio at 37.
This is the market because more people want
to live in Santa Barbara than in Parma.
That drives prices up because there's a limited
supply of housing and space and jobs in Santa
Barbara.
If the politics of California disgusts people
and they move out, demand will go down and
it'll get cheaper.
And wherever those people go, demand will
go up and it will get more expensive.
If all the people wanting to live in Santa
Barbara go and live in Parma, Ohio, Parma,
Ohio, will become more expensive.
I don't know if health care will get any better,
maybe over time with additional tax revenue,
who knows?
But this is sort of like the way the market
works and these people seem to very much not
understand it.
So a disaster disaster for Republicans in
California.
Let's hope it's a sign of things to come in
the 2022 midterms.
But House races in Florida are very different
than a recall election in a full state election
like California.
So let's not get ahead of ourselves.